[Musik]
mein name ist mathias entstand ich bin
geschäftsführer anklingt ihm entstand
mein name ist prozent alles klar ich bin
zweiter ausbildungsjahres als
altenpflegerin seit zweier bin ich ein
ambulanter pflegedienst mein name ist
hase ich bin krankenpfleger arbeitet
einen ambulanten pflegedienst der circa
105 patienten versorgt aktuell genau ich
bin mit dem auto unterwegs zu den
patienten wo ich zu den nach hause
fahren und die dort versorge vor ort in
der mobilen pflege fahren die
krankenpflege zu den patienten nach
hause
ein wichtiger aufgabenbereich die
grundpflege
hier geht es um die grundversorgung des
patienten der krankenpflege wäscht und
pflegt ihn
er muss viel mit dem patienten sprechen
[Musik]
außerdem gibt es weitere wichtige
aufgaben wie den blutzucker zu messen
[Musik]
oder verbände zu wechseln
alle tätigkeiten die man bei jedem
patienten erledigt hat müssen
dokumentiert werden
auch ein gespräch mit den angehörigen
kann dazu gehören mehr über den beruf
des krankenpflegers erfahrt ihr im
nächsten teil
heute
das machen wir eine kleine pflege mit
land berlin erstmal genau dafür den
blutzucker messen und entsprechend das
insulin spritzen und dann nochmal die
medikamente kontrollieren und dem
frechen genauer als nächstes wenn wir
das in den nächsten patienten gehen die
hat eine infizierte bisswunde genau dies
vom hund gebissen worden die wunderschön
verziert ist soweit vom strom solche
worden und soll jetzt durch den
pflegedienst quasi durch uns versorgt
werden ist er dann abgeheilt ist genau
richtig wir würden am anfang gucken dass
wir das über buch lesen was die kollegen
eingetragen haben und gibt es
irgendwelche informationen hat jemand
ein arzttermin oder irgendwas genau dann
wird wie schlüssel nehmen damit wir dann
auch in die wohnung kommen dann wäre ich
soweit bereit hast du noch fragen
bis jetzt okay aber wir würden uns jetzt
die zwei schlüssel von patienten jetzt
erst mal mitnehmen
das wäre einmal den herum ich habe das
andere patienten noch das sind die zwei
schlüssel haben wir brauchen
[Musik]
ich habe heute eine auszubildende dabei
dass die vertriebswege
wir haben sicher nur ein danke papa war
ich schon sehnlichst gut geschlafen
sieht man doch ja ich habe heute die
vertriebs ja dabei das ist die neue
auszubildende
diese pakete wir würden uns keine wahl
vorbereiten damit wir zu ihm kommen und
uns um sie kümmern ja dann fangen wir
direkt mal damit an die beine zu waschen
okay okay dass die patientenakte hier
vorne hast du mir da standen dann ganz
einfach die stammdaten sehen dann hast
du die harmlosen die ja für uns relevant
sind zum beispiel erzählt diabetes
mellitus wird insulin pflichtigen ist ja
das müssen wir beachten nachher dass ich
einmal die leistung sondern kannst du
sehen was wir genau machen also am 14
er sollte kleinen flex reingemacht mir
die beine wird
etwas besonderes war was genau das so
haben verstanden was sagen die hände
dann gehen das einmal zusammen durch die
patrizia begeht einmal die beine waschen
ja ich werde ein bisschen drauf gucken
und schauen ob alles so weit okay ist
und auch etwas verbessern können ja und
haben doch möchten sie sei eben die
wasser haaren bitte möchte sie seife im
wasser haben ja das steht schon alles da
vorne bereit beim guten schuss des
völlig aus
wichtig ist den schritt immer den
patienten zu erklären genau was du
eigentlich bist dass du das rechte bein
anheben damit er sich nicht erschreckt
und genau ist hier jetzt erst mal
vielleicht den ball und ich fange mit
waschen
genau wir stehen diesmal gegen die haar
richtung gerade morgens weil wir damit
den patienten aktivieren ja abends
würden wir zum beispiel mit der arge
stunden ja ja wir würden als nächstes
die blutzuckermessung machen um zu
gucken wie der blutzucker ist und
entsprechend seien insulin spritzen
damit er dann frühstücken kann ja ich
würde gerne einmal den blutzucker bei
ihnen müssen ja da dürfen sie mir einmal
eine hand zur verfügung stellen
genau dann nehmen wir uns denn hier ist
ja mal den blutzucker es regnet
du würdest hier eine quasi ziehen das
ist ein rastet dass sie hier den punkt
wurde draufdrücken kannst du und ich bin
dann aber raus wenn du den ersten
tropfen weg das ist wahrscheinlich
und dann hat sie hier das gerät wurde
das wird auf trägst du siehst hier die
markierung hier kommt das hoffen
blutdruck und dann berechnet das gerät
hier quasi den blutzuckergehalt aus 1960
das ist völlig in ordnung
dementsprechend so haben wir 160 ist der
blutzucker das ist in ordnung
jaja aber fangen wir gleich mal wirklich
mit leben gefüllt dann kriegen ja gut
dann haben wir noch die dokumentation
immer wieder ganz wichtig genau richtig
wir haben unter drei und haben wir die
leistungsphase die ist ganz wichtig weil
die rechnen wir nachher mit der
krankenkasse unter pflegekasse genau du
siehst du die leistungen sind schon
geplant
genau wir würden uns dann ja quasi
einfach nur eintragen
mit uhrzeit und handzeichen dürfe dass
wir diese leistung erbracht haben ja und
du siehst es steht wirklich jede
leistung drin die wir auch erbringen
alles was wir jetzt beobachten genau
alles was so außergewöhnlich ist wenn
der patient sagt er fühlt sich wohl
alles so gut dann muss das hier gar
nicht drin stehen soll davon gehen wir
aus den herr nonnenmacher ihrem partner
versorgt der ist super motiviert hilft
mit man muss zwischendurch immer impulse
setzen
ich wollte das dann auch kognitiv nicht
umgesetzt krieg aber ansonsten ist für
uns eigentlich ja sie machen das auch
immer prima sagt sie da sind dass das
wirklich toll also wären da manchmal
solche probleme aber das wirklich eine
super hilfe das freut uns doch zu laden
[Musik]
so voll war wir sehen uns helfen also
vielen dank für ihre hilfe
kein problem es ist klasse und vor
schluss passierte eine basis x games
[Musik]
genau die mit der effizienten wunder die
versorgen wir heute noch genauso wichtig
ist dass kleins zwischendurch immer hoch
zu legen gerade wenn sie ruhig haben sie
gucken oder so oder mal mit change
machen
genau damit die lymphflüssigkeit einfach
ein bisschen abschließen kann fördert
auch immer die wundheilung damit die
wunderbar getroffen haben vor haben wir
das schön desinfiziert und damit wie die
bakterien keime einmal reduzieren oder
abtöten können
die wurde sieht ja insgesamt deutlich
besser ausland oder so und besser genau
die infektion das noch sichtbar
dieses ist er mit den schmerzen aktuell
naja könnte besser gehen wichtig ist
dass man das runde exot aufnehmen kann
das einfach nicht durch dezimiert
das ist immer wichtig das war musste und
auch ruhig dann auch die patienten
fragen ob das zu fest ist oder nicht
mehr weil jetzt haben wir die
möglichkeit dann auch noch etwas zu tun
geht es so wunderbar
es hat das bein wieder ablegen genau und
einmal gut festhalten
wichtig ist dann auch wirklich die
mullbinde nochmal zu fixieren damit dass
sowohl für das social haftet auch ganz
gut für nahe weil gerade am
unterschenkel die patienten sicher noch
viel bewegen möchte oder wird das nicht
runter rutscht und dann kannst du hier
noch mal kontrollieren wenn er so ein
finger rein passt das ist auch nicht zu
eng ist ja doch ganz ruhig mal probieren
ja genau
ansonsten soll bald drauf lassen nicht
drangehen und auch nicht nass machen
prima ist klar
[Musik]
wichtig ist uns dass jemand mit berbens
arbeiten möchte mir liebe hat zu
hilfsbedürftigen menschen müsse
pflegebedürftigen menschen haben
begeisterung im team hat auch zu
arbeiten gemeinsam dinge anzugehen
partie man muss sich wirklich in die
lage der leute hineinversetzen können um
sie dort abzuholen wo sie auch stehen
man muss wirklich flexibel sein
kein tag ist wie der andere
offen für neue dinge sein und fragen
auch bereits ein ja neue dinge zu lernen
man soll das entwickelt sich einfach
immer weiter gibt die möglichkeit
ungelernt in der pflege zu beginnen
da braucht man dann gewissen zeitraum
von erfahrungen sammelt und dann kann
man sich halt auch weiterbilden in dem
bereich die ausbildung dauert insgesamt
drei jahre
die dinge die man in der ausbildung
lernt sind einmal die anatomie des
menschlichen körpers die
krankheitsbilder sind ganz wichtig dann
vor allem die pflege wie westland
patienten worauf kommt es an
laut beobachtungen als solche dinge und
ein wichtiger punkt ist die
kommunikation und die gesprächsführung
wie man wirklich mit den leuten umgeht
und
sprich auch angehörigenarbeit meistens
dessen in einer altenpflegeausbildung
auch schon fachabitur verbunden so dass
man sogar nach der ausbildung studieren
könnte ansonsten gibt es zu den stränden
dass man sich zu den experten entwickelt
was zum beispiel wunsch management
angeht palliativpflege oder halt in
richtung leitung pflegedienstleitungen
um dann halt auch verantwortung
übernehmen ist im bereich ganzen bereich
dazu führen das wichtigste für mich ist
immer wirklich den patienten individuell
zu sehen sie so zu respektieren wie er
ist
wir kommen als gast sein seien zwar in
seinem eigenheim genau holen ihn dort ab
wo er steht das ist ganz ganz wichtig
und vor allem dinge zu tun die auch
wirklich beruf macht spaß weil das ein
beruf ist kann man ganz viel
zurückbekommt bei jedem patienten
bekommt man entweder ein dankeschön oder
zumindest ein lächeln auf dem gesicht
und das gibt einem ganz viel zurück
der beruf macht sinn man weiß eigentlich
was man getan hat wenn man nach hause
geht
es erfüllt ein
genau das war nochmal so die dinge die
ich mir als ziel gesetzt habe als im
büro vergabe genau die mich einfach auch
zufrieden stellen
am ende des tages